if you're already concerned about the
direction of the United States I don't
know that today's program is going to
make you feel that much better or we had
two major rallies in the United States
uh this weekend
um each more depraved than the last we
had the March for Life anti-abortion
rally which we're going to get to we
also had the anti-vaccine defeat the
mandates rally in Washington DC and this
rally was headlined and this makes me
really sad because I know the guy very
nice guy in in private uh not a dumb guy
uh Robert F Kennedy Jr who as some of
you know I I've had dinner with in a
small group and and is someone that
through environmental lawyers I know is
is kind of in my circle uh Robert F
Kennedy Jr headlining the defeat the
mandates rally in Washington D.C
and
um saying that vaccine mandates are
worse than the Nazi Holocaust I mean
this really is tough to watch the
context of this rally before we get to
the clip is that these this was
supposedly an anti-mandate rally not an
anti-vaxx rally but a lot of the people
there are historically anti-vaxx Robert
F Kennedy Jr at one point I tuned in and
there was a woman talking about vaccines
causing autism I mean for all the claims
that they're only against the mandates
it was all of the typical anti-vax stuff
a rock Dr Robert Malone was there Dr
Peter mccullo sort of a who's who of Joe
Rogan guests and
um I'm gonna play this clip for you and
it it's this is maybe one of the most
disgusting things I've seen and it's
particularly
um uh disturbing because this this is a
guy I know who I I had dinner with once
and he seemed completely connected to
reality so here is uh Robert F Kennedy
Jr listen to this this clip going viral
yesterday take a look
how many you could you could cross the
Alps into Switzerland you can hide in an
attic like Anne Frank did
I visited in 1962 East Germany with my
father and met people who had climbed
the wall and escaped so it was possible
maybe I threw him but it was possible
today the mechanisms are being put in
place I will make us none of us can run
and none of us this is absolutely
unconscionable and disgusting now it's
also historically inaccurate in the
sense that
they they got Anne Frank and her family
and killed her so she was only eve even
if you concede the completely disgusting
vile trivialization of the Holocaust and
you you know you put aside 10 different
things
they got Anne Frank and Frank couldn't
hide at the end of the day they got her
and they got her family and they killed
her but what is the obsession here with
trivializing the trauma of the Holocaust
vaccine requirements to get your kid in
school are like when the Nazis killed
the Jews conducted disgusting medical
experiments on them imprisoned them in
work camps gassed Jews that's like when
a school says for everybody's safety
Little Joey's got to get a few vaccines
um and there was a very good tweet from
the Auschwitz Memorial Museum account
saying quote exploiting of the tragedy
of people who suffered were humiliated
tortured and murdered by the
totalitarian regime of Nazi Germany
including children like Anne Frank in a
debate about vaccines and limitations
during Global pandemic is a sad symptom
of moral and intellectual Decay and
understand that Bobby Kennedy's not even
just exploiting the tragedy of the
Holocaust he's saying it wasn't as bad
as what's quote happening to them now
and of course nothing is happening now I
want to play a couple other parts of
this
let me just play it and and then I'll
comment because there's also some other
interpretation not interpretations
there's some other aspects to this
15 000 low orbit satellites wait what
Bill Gates says his 65 000 satellites
alone
we'll be able to look at every square
inch in the planet 24 hours a day we
already can by the way
they're putting in 5G
to harvest our data and control our
Behavior digital currency that will
allow them to punish us from a distance
and cut off our food supply
so it's like he goes into other
conspiracies I actually this this is
where Bobby Kennedy's intelligence
actually comes through it sounds like
he's doing all of the same conspiracies
that a lot of the anti-vaxxers do 5G and
you know government control and all
these different things but if you listen
he's actually being really careful
because even when he talks about 5G he's
like they're going to be able to harvest
our data and control our Behavior he's
not actually saying the stuff the 5G
people say about
um neurological control he's saying he's
sort of saying like 5G has more
bandwidth and thus it'll be easier to
harvest data about our activities online
and then use that to guide us to buy
certain products or like but my point
here is he seems to know that that part
is total BS and he's like stopping short
and using coded language that sort of
sounds like the conspiracy but really
isn't same thing with cryptocurrency
like they're going to use cryptocurrency
to to kill our supply chain that he he's
virtue signaling to the conspiracy
theorists who are buying his book and
making it number one on Amazon and
whatever else the book about Dr fauci if
you can imagine
but that when I see that is when I think
this may be to some degree a little bit
of a grift and he may not believe
everything he's saying doesn't make it
any less damaging and we have to condemn
this disgusting stuff many appeals to
violence from the crowd goers if you
looked in the crowd the signs people
were holding there was one that said
shoot those who try to kidnap and
vaccinate your child and that quotes
Exodus 21 16 which reads quote anyone
who kidnaps someone is to be put to
death okay lots of Holocaust
trivialization
people with the stars of David some of
them you know some we some call them
Jewish Stars they were all over the
place we have one on the screen for you
and then a really bizarre moment some of
the musical entertainment
um this there's like a sort of dance
thing that was going on it did look like
the person dancing was having a stroke
or a medical event of some kind like
every aspect of this was insane let me
just play this for you if you're not
watching today if you're just listening
just imagine someone appearing to have a
stroke all for the bills
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
anyway hopefully they did get medical
help for that individual if needed
disgusting rally and a really a sign
that things are not going very well in
this country and then we've got the
other rally to talk about there was
another rally this past weekend it
wasn't just the crazy anti-vaxx rally
there was also the completely unhinged
more religiously oriented anti-choice
rally they call it the March 4 Life it's
really the March against Choice against
bodily autonomy against allowing people
mostly women along with their Partners
who could be male or female
to make decisions about what's best for
their health and their pregnancies this
is the very long long time uh uh in
existence now March for Life and many of
you are already familiar with the
endless hypocrisies with these March for
Life people but the good liars did some
really good work they went out to the
March for Life and they interviewed some
of the anti-abortion people and they
seemed completely unable to understand
the irony and hypocrisy of the things
they believe here is a really great
example of an anti-choice guy being
interviewed about my body my choice
which he says doesn't make any sense
when it comes to abortion but when
presented with that when it comes to
vaccines all of a sudden he says yeah my
body my choice completely impervious to
uh hypocrisy take a look at this what
message would you have to women who are
considering having an abortion when uh
when a woman becomes pregnant there's
two bodies there
it's not one and it's not my body my
choice oh it's
care for care for the child there's
adoption there's
there's other routes to go
I know what do you what do you say to
people out there that that
um say that they don't want to get the
covered vaccine
um
if the my body my choice works for
abortion why doesn't the same work for
the vaccine which of course you could
say the same thing right if wait hold on
a second if my body my choice works for
the vaccine why couldn't it work for
abortion like without a hint of irony
if it's my body it should be my choice
of whether or not I want to back back to
me
the the theme Here by the way is a lot
of just telling other people what to do
another really common one is never ever
ever
abortion
because
there's adoption and a lot of these
people that advocate for that they go
well no I mean I'm not adopting anyone
but other people should all right so
here's another interesting interview
from uh the uh the good thieves the good
liar sorry I Saw the Sign choose
adoption
yeah and how many how many children have
you adopted not able to adopt I'd love
to adopt we weren't able to adopt and
how many children have you adopted none
I have two of my own yeah and how many
children how many children have you
adopted no
and how many and how many children have
you done
so you've adopted I have two of my own
okay
the message okay so understand that this
is all about telling other people
don't have an abortion ever because
instead you should pursue adoption and
also telling other people go and adopt I
mean we're not doing it no we're not
going to participate in any of that but
other people should not have abortions
and then other people should adopt their
babies all about what other people are
supposed to do here's a bonus this is
Gene Mancini who runs the March for Life
saying that they have been praying and
fasting to earn or to end abortion I
didn't know that they were fasting take
a listen to this I have never seen the
enthusiasm of the pro-life movement like
I've seen this year it's like we have
prayed and fasted for years for this
moment and we're so hopeful and positive
that row will be overturned I had no
idea that they were fasting to end
abortion now I don't know a lot about
fasting the closest I would ever get
would be as a kid
the first two hours of the Passover
Seder
felt like I was fasting even though I
had not actually fasted and until the
matzo ball soup came out and we could
have the food that's I so I have to
admit I don't know a lot about religious
fasting but I did not realize that they
thought fasting would end abortion I I
had no idea
um every little detail about this is
outrageous and uh just just rally after
rally and the fact that people go to
this stuff really showing us the dire
state of the discourse in the United
States speaking of dire state of
discourse I have a an invitation to some
of you
um this weekend Saturday January 29th
Donald Trump is doing another 2022 rally
this one is in Conroe Texas we would
like to hire someone from our audience
to go to the rally and interview people
live we'll be on a stream and some they
can they'll do some interviews and also
I will feed them some questions that I
have for the Trump rally goers if you so
here's the deal we will pay you we only
need like one team probably a One camera
person or you know maybe maybe uh one
you might even be able to film yourself
but if you can get yourself to Conroe if
you live in the area and you can figure
out how to get in right like either you
get a ticket or you get a media
registration we can't help with those
details but we will pay we will pay you
to go and do this and you have the
equipment which is like a phone at this
point basically
um we want someone to go and do some
interviews at the rally for us so get in
touch info davidpackman.com don't ask us
how to get in
you you have to look and see what the
ticket situation is like we we're just
it's too soon to handle all of the
logistics but we will pay uh we'll come
up with something Fair uh info
davidpackman.com ideally you would live
nearby it would be easy for you to get
there
um get in touch if you would be
interested in doing that info at
davidpackman.com
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right we I have some amazing video
for you today now if you're allergic to
cringe I would tune away but if you
relish it if you live for the cringe
then this is the segment for you I've
been talking now for a very long time
about how the Republican party has moved
away from even pretending to be about
policy this sort of started during the
Civil Rights movement in the late 50s
60s and into the 70s it you can actually
Trace Republicans not being about policy
all the way back to that but in the more
modern era the Republican Party
abandoning policy was accelerated when
Newt Gingrich took over the control of
speakership of the House of
Representatives in 1994 when kind of
dim-witted George W bush became
president Republicans moved further uh
away from being about policy and instead
being about cultural issues ETC and
memes and and slogans when Barack Obama
became president his being half black
triggered so many of the more racist and
xenophobic right-wingers that the focus
for further went away from policy and
more into personality stuff and culture
War issues and under Donald Trump they
pretended to even care about policy and
Joe Biden pointed this out at his press
conference last week remember Joe Biden
saying what are Republicans for remember
this
think about this what are Republicans
for
what are they for
name me one thing they're for so Jake
Tapper did something great he had
Republican senator Joni Ernst on his
program she's from Iowa
excuse me and he said can you name three
things that Republicans actually stand
for all of these Republicans are furious
with Joe Biden because he said they're
not for anything but tell us three
things that you are for and it is as
wild and vapid as you can imagine let's
take a look at this and let we're gonna
go piece by piece here
so Senate uh minority leader Mitch
McConnell has said he does not feel that
uh Republicans need to present an agenda
to the country and generally speaking I
understand the politics midterms tend to
be referenda on the people who are
running the country but what are three
things that Republicans will do uh if
you recapture the senate in the midterms
well I think that Republicans stand for
a strong free and prosperous nation and
a free prosperous Nation okay well let's
talk policy so uh one we need to tackle
the issue of inflation Biden is facing a
40-year high with the inflation rate and
Iowans and all Americans are feeling
those pressures so alleviating those
pressures on our families would be a job
number one covet so okay now when you
listen to what you did there she
identified a problem that's not a policy
and it's not a solution she says
inflation is high under Biden and so we
would reduce inflation okay but that's
that's not policy governments can use
wage and price controls to fight
inflation but that can accelerate a
recession and create job losses you can
look at contractionary monetary policy
to fight inflation reduce the money
supply uh look at bond prices increase
interest rate she she's identified a
problem it's like how would you solve
this cardiac issue that this person is
having well this individual is having a
heart attack so we would deal with that
no right but what I'm saying what is it
that you would do to fix and deal with
the heart attack okay that's number one
it's just stating a problem let's
continue she said now she's going into
covid well we need to make sure that
American families have access to testing
but certainly we want to make sure that
they are getting their children back
into school and that their workplaces
are are safe and they can return to work
now understand that that's completely
vapid first of all she didn't care about
testing when testing was a disaster
under Trump so you know that that's
number one number two most schools are
open some schools have gone temporarily
remote some have been forced to close
because too many teachers got covered
and there's nobody there to teach
there's nothing there's no policy there
um and then as well we need to to focus
on uh additional things like uh you know
foreign relations with our allies
because obviously with National Security
we are under a lot of pressure right now
so Republicans believe in that that is
nothing you're not saying anything she
says the three priorities would be
bringing down inflation but she doesn't
say how
fighting covid when she didn't care
about that under Trump and doesn't
actually say what would be done and most
of the things she's saying she wants to
see are already happening like most
schools open and workplaces open and
then they would do foreign relations
they really aren't for anything she was
given an opportunity she could have said
what we are going to do very
specifically is we will uh changed or we
will we will try to get the FED to
change direction on interest rates which
we believe would get inflation from X to
Y we would do uh this or that on even if
they're crazy things like we we would
force schools to be open and be
penalized like even if it's crazy
say what you will do given an
opportunity and has nothing literally
nothing they aren't for anything Joe
Biden was exactly right in pointing that
out but the crazy part is
they might still take over the House and
Senate even not being for anything
because it's not clear they need to be
for anything the vast majority of their
voters don't care that they aren't for
anything and that's really the scariest
part of all of this we now are learning
more and more about what was actually a
coordinated plan to send fraudulent
electors in multiple states to
Washington DC to try to steal the
election from Joe Biden as a reminder
Joe Biden won the election in November
of 2020. there was a concerted effort
made across a number of different areas
to try to steal the election by Donald
Trump we now know that Rudy Giuliani was
at the helm of a fake elector plot in
seven states Rudy may now have legal
problems as a result
CNN reporting Washington I'm sorry Trump
campaign officials led by Giuliani
oversaw efforts in December of 2020 to
put forward illegitimate electors from
seven states that Trump lost according
to three sources with direct knowledge
of the scheme the sources said members
of Trump's former campaign team
were far more involved than previously
known a core tenet of the broader plot
to overturn Joe Biden's Victory on
January 6th Giuliani and allies
coordinated the nuts and bolts of the
process on a state-by-state level the
sources told CNN One Source said there
were multiple planning calls between
Trump campaign officials and Republican
state operatives and that Giuliani
participated in at least one call The
Source also said that the Trump campaign
lined up supporters to fill elector
slots secured meeting rooms and state
houses for the fake electors to meet on
December 14th and circulated drafts of
fake certificates that were ultimately
sent to the National Archives
Trump and some of his top advisors
publicly encouraged the alternate
elector scheme in Pennsylvania Georgia
Michigan Arizona Wisconsin Nevada and
New York but behind the scenes Giuliani
and Trump campaign officials
actively choreographed the process the
source said they were going to try to
dump in big massive dumps fake electors
to vote for Trump instead of Biden we
already knew this remember that we
actually talked about this um not long
ago one of the Republican lawmakers who
signed the fake Arizona document was
state representative Jake Hoffman he was
confronted about this and said who
organized this who told you to show up
that day
and signed this fraudulent document he
ran away from reporters remember we
looked at this clip when Bram wants to
ask a real question happy to have a
conversation with him okay thank you sir
I'm asking you that question I wonder
what Authority did you find yourself as
an elected so an unprecedented times
unprecedented action is occurred there
is no case law there's no precedent that
exists as to whether or not a an
election that is currently being
litigated in the courts
has do standing which is why we felt it
appropriate to provide Congress and the
vice president with uh dueling opinions
did you have direction from anybody in
doing this was it was it you 11 yourself
to doing this or did someone give you
advice on the matter in which you can do
it
so I'm simply I was one of the electors
right I'm not in charge of the elector
so you would how did you hear about you
you wouldn't you would need to ask the
partnership how did you hear about the
plan were you just told to be something
that you would need to ask the party
chair that way but you're the you're the
person who received the call you showed
up right how did you know to show up
that day so as I said you can go ahead
and ask the party chair the logistics of
it ask for how you got a phone call to
go somewhere you're welcome to talk to
them about this you do not know how you
arrived at a place thank you I
appreciate your time you really not I
know how you got a call have a great one
the other question
so this needs to be taken completely
seriously if at the individual level you
fill out a fake ballot sometimes you go
to jail we've seen that happen at the
individual level they tried to steal the
whole election and all of a sudden it's
like well are we gonna do anything about
that might we file charges it's a
federal crime to interfere with the mail
but if you're the Postmaster General you
can sabotage the whole system make it
more difficult to vote by mail and
there's no repercussions it's common
that at the street level things are
punished and then at the structural
level they are not now all of this goes
back to one of the many prongs that they
had in place to try to steal the
election one prong was that if there are
states that they just won't accept were
won by Joe Biden on January 6th or
December 14th depending on how the plan
went instead of sending only the
Democratic electors to DC what
Republicans wanted to do was send an
alternate slate of electors and they
wanted to force Mike Pence when it came
time for Arizona's votes to be counted
for example for Mike Pence to say
because the results of Arizona seem fake
I mean I don't even know how you say it
and not sound like a complete
authoritarian clown
instead of accepting the Democratic
votes from Arizona we have these other
what's the number seven 14 I don't
remember these other electors from
Arizona how do you vote we vote for
Trump that was the plan now that plan
failed but understand that if they had
had
different people in place at the state
level
if Trump had had the generals with him
as was warned now a couple weeks ago by
retired military generals the outcome
could have been different it's really
great that it failed given how badly it
could have gone but this was a plan for
a complete coup including possibly
declaring a state of emergency was being
floated trying to get the military to
enforce a different winner fake electors
flipping states by pressuring
secretaries of State they are going to
try it again
we just saw they don't even know Joni
Ernst asked what are three things you
would do she has nothing
so they're not trying to win on policy
they are going to try this again and we
have to be ready for it and we'll have
more on this on our Instagram find us on
Instagram at davidpackman show
you value what we do at
do and show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show I have a
truly glorious story for you today of
justice and Instant Karma and we can say
that that's what it is because
thankfully nobody got hurt this could
have gone a different way and we would
we could be talking about a tragedy here
fortunately nobody got hurt what am I
talking about David sir what on Earth
are you talking about a Virginia mom
went to a school board meeting and
threatened that if her children were
made to wear masks in school she would
show up
with loaded guns loaded guns this is in
larae Virginia
the woman is Amelia Ruffner King she has
been charged with making an oral threat
while on school property and has been
released on a five thousand dollar Bond
all of this relates to these threats
that she made when speaking to the
school board listen to this and pay
particular attention to whether it
sounds like she's making a joke here
because that's an issue take a listen no
mask mandates my child my children will
not come to school on Monday with a mask
on
all right that's not happening and I
will bring every single gun loaded and
ready to I I will call every that's
three minutes if you come past your time
it's a policy
thank you
I'll see you all on Monday
I will bring every single gun loaded if
you have a mask policy and I will see
y'all on Monday
she later after being arrested and
charged which is exactly what should
happen she apologized to the board she
said she wasn't referring to actual
firearms
I will murder every last one of you with
the loaded guns I own which I will be
with here on Monday January 24th oh I
didn't mean literal guns no I mean I
meant you know I meant my uh I met my
verbal Firepower and that's that's
absolutely all I meant these people need
these people are a danger
and it needs to be taken very very
seriously the school board meeting
happened just after Glenn Younkin signed
an executive order allowing parents to
opt their kids out of mask mandates so
it actually didn't even matter whether
the school put in a mask mandate because
Glenn youngin gave outrageous parents
like this woman the ability to opt their
kids out of such a mandate anyway it
should not be written off as just the
idol rantings uh or whatever every
single one of these people has to be
taken very seriously and the reason we
know that is we see the real world
violence that these people are
committing so it cannot be laughed off
to any degree and in this particular
case she was immediately arrested
hopefully she will think twice about
doing this again that being said it
probably doesn't dissuade her
if she was determined to show up with
guns I don't think an arrest and bailing
out on five grand Bond actually changes
your mind I mean these people are so out
there that if they really believe I must
show up with guns to defend my children
against masks getting arrested and
bailed out very quickly is not going to
dissuade them so probably this is
someone who should continue to be
monitored and see uh what she's up to
not anyone I would want anywhere near
anybody I know or care about that's for
sure I am not being hyperbolic here I am
going to show you clips of what I
believe is Donald Trump's worst
interview uh that I've ever seen him
give and I I'm not going to say it's
significantly worse than the Jonathan
Swann axios interview it may be equally
bad
but this is at least equally bad in
terms of being Trump's worst interview
that I have ever seen uh I read that
this took place and I couldn't believe
it I had to go and find the clip for
myself I read that Sean Hannity asked
Trump about Biden's strategy of
metaphorically banging your head against
the wall and expecting results from that
it was a metaphor the metaphor of
banging your head against the wall
Donald Trump answered that the wall
would have been done in three weeks if
he had been re-elected
please understand what I'm saying
Hannity talks about metaphorically
banging your head against the wall
and Trump answers about the literal wall
that he claims he was building on the
U.S Mexico border and people are
questioning Joe Biden's cognitive State
listen to this so you know it's you know
you keep banging your head against the
wall why would you expect a different
result
so we would have had the wall completed
in three weeks it was largely completed
so
guys it's this is a former president
it's a former president
um at another point during the interview
Hannity says Trump created monoclonal
antibodies now I've heard Trump be
wrongly credited with creating the
vaccines which he didn't do
Hannity is saying Trump created the
monoclonal antibodies as well I thought
it was regeneron take a listen you left
office with three vaccines and
monoclonal antibodies that you had
created which to this day I think is the
the best therapeutic I advise people to
talk to them it's a therapeutic
um what Trump now created the antibodies
too like what what what is happening
people watch this people just on the
basis of those two clips alone
this is the most insane interview I've
seen Trump do right up there with the
Jonathan Swann interview but then you if
I told you this you'd say David sir it's
2022 this can't be going on Trump is
still bragging about the dementia test
he's still talking about it
do you believe he's struggling
cognitively because that question was
raised about you and I've been around
you long enough to know that that that's
not a problem for you at all
well I went and took a test and as uh Dr
Ronnie Jackson who's great great guy now
he's a congressman and they love him in
Texas but he said he aced it and I don't
think he ever saw anyone Ace it and I
immediately said because they started
passing the false narrative
guys he's still bragging about the
dimensions as he thinks it's an IQ test
he he thinks that doing well on a test
meant to screen out relatively serious
dementia that he's worthy of Mensa
membership or so I mean it it's 2022 and
he's still doing it in a moment totally
Beyond parody in criticizing Joe Biden's
thus far handling of the Ukraine Russia
situation Trump says he never had a
problem with Ukraine
what about the impeachment related to
Ukraine what what these things would
have happened you wouldn't have had
inflation you wouldn't have had Ukraine
problems with Russia it was all working
out everything was fine the guy was
impeached over his problems with Ukraine
continuing now that I've never seen an
interview like that it's every answer is
from another planet Trump says windmills
are ruining the atmosphere guys wind
farms wind power and if you could start
that up again and stop with all of the
windmills all over
Mr you you look at what's happening with
these beautiful prairies and plains and
these gorgeous areas of our country
where they have these rusting hulks put
up all over the place where that are
noisy they're killing the birds I mean I
I don't get the environmental sense it's
a very expensive form probably the most
expensive form of energy Now understand
there's we could just do an hour on wind
energy understand that each of these
things has been studied first and
foremost when Technologies are newer
they are nowhere near full efficiency so
without a doubt wind power will become
more efficient meaning being able to
harvest more power generate more power
from the same amount of wind that's
that's we've seen it with solar panels
we've seen it all over the place the
bird stuff has been studied extensively
and while
um it is true that some birds are killed
due to wind farms the number of animals
killed by fossil fuels is orders of
magnitude greater on a per energy basis
it's been studied but this is the stuff
that the fox audience accepts
uncritically now last clip here and this
is again I I can't believe we are it's
we if there's ever been evidence that
we're in a simulation it's that Trump's
still doing this stuff Trump again brags
about the size of the crowd at the
insurrection
and with a lot less than 20 000 troops
also the fact is I knew it was going to
be a massive rally because this was a
protest rally against the election which
they considered to be totally rigged
they were right and this was a protest
against the election and I was told by
so many people oh we're going down on
the sixth we're going down and I that's
why I met with
the top people the top people in
Military and other places and I said I
think this is going to be a lot of
people coming down I can tell you I
spoke I believe it was the biggest crowd
I've ever spoken to it was massive the
absolute biggest crowd ever incited by a
president to attempt an Insurrection we
have never seen anything like this truly
and the majority of the Republican Party
based on all recent polling wants four
more years of that and they may get it
they may get it depending on what
happens in 2022 and of course what
happens with Trump's health and whether
Joe Biden runs again and all these
different things but
more than half of them want it and they
may get it which is absolutely
horrifying
subscribe to our YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash the davidpackman show
watch the full hour-long show individual
Clips all of our interviews and
everything else from the show and when
you subscribe make sure to click that
Bell button to be notified about every
new video
so dozens of you emailed me over the
weekend saying I have to see this
segment of Fox News propaganda's Tucker
Carlson sort of bemoaning that he is
going to find the new way that M Ms are
anthropomorphized in commercials less
arousing and less of a turn on to him
um I as many of you know I kind of don't
pay much attention to the news over the
weekend and then a Sunday evening I'll
start picking out stories for the Monday
show and I didn't know what to expect
based on all of the emails I had from
people saying check out the Tucker thing
it is downright creepy and bizarre now
let me give you guys some context
Eminem's announced I don't know do
people even do I need to explain
Eminem's M Ms are this chocolate candy
there's regular M Ms there's peanut M
M's there's peanut butter M M's you know
all these different kinds and in the
commercials they are anthropomorphized
meaning they are drawn with eyes and
shoes and legs and all this different
stuff apparently among other changes the
brown m m is going to be redrawn as
slightly less
uh stereotypically
attractive I don't even know what to
call it like brown M M's high heels will
be slightly lower it and Tucker believes
that this is part of the big culture war
that he thinks is being fought and he's
angry that brown Eminem won't be as
attractive to him this is beyond belief
take a look at this finally tonight we
don't usually give story tips to NPR but
here's a story they might want to cover
pretty soon in doubtless will Eminem's
the candy company it's just announced
that it's redesigning its cartoon
characters whoa to be more gender
inclusive
[Music]
bet you didn't think
Eminem's were pushing intolerance but
they were they've been changed you're
seeing the changes right now on your
screen the green Eminem you will notice
is no longer wearing sexy boots now
she's wearing sensible sneakers that's
going to make it really really tough for
Tucker to enjoy looking at these images
though because it's it's just not
attractive enough to him why the change
well according to Eminem's quote we all
win when we see more women in leading
roles because leading women do not wear
sexy boots leading women to wear frumpy
shoes the frumpier the better that's the
rule
the other big change is that the brown m
m has quote transitioned from high
stilettos to lower block heels whoa also
less sexy that's progress M Ms will not
be satisfied until every last cartoon
character is deeply unappealing and
totally androgynous until the moment you
wouldn't want to have a drink with any
one of them that's the goal when you're
totally turned off
we've achieved Equity they've won
meanwhile in a nod to the burgeoning
wellness movement the orange m m will
quote acknowledge and embrace his
anxiety
and actually if you look at him the
orange m m does appear very anxious
maybe he doesn't like all the ugly new
shoes he sees around him maybe he liked
the sexy boots yeah
um does anybody else find it strange
that Tucker Carlson is so keyed into how
attractive he finds anthropomorphized
chocolate candy to be does anybody care
about this and in also
Close Your Eyes For a Moment let me take
you on a journey close your eyes it's
2017.
Trump has just come to power and I tell
you about a segment in which Tucker
Carlson is bemoaning the fact that the
brown m m is now being anthropomorphized
in a less appealing way to him sexually
you would have said David that's an SNL
skit that's SNL 2017. you would have
said that's a parody but it is actually
now the culture war that they are
fighting and some people see this and
they actually get angry hey man did you
see what they're doing with Eminem's man
freaking let's go Brandon Joe Biden
these people communist it's terrible
liberal crazy the the it's what they've
done with M M's is just unconscionable
yeah yeah I saw and green also remember
the shoes the green used to have what is
wrong with these people
but they don't have anything else I mean
we we watched Joni Ernst earlier
struggle to name anything that
Republicans would do
if they won in November and they may win
Republicans may win the Senate they may
win the house
and they can't articulate anything they
would do I guess maybe Tucker would want
to bring back hot brown Eminem
uh but that's not really much of a
policy that does anything for working
people and
um it is
I I was like no my audience is
exaggerated this is not what the clip
was and it's exactly what the clip was
and it's extraordinarily disturbing hey
uh Donald Trump was on to something when
he indirectly criticized Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis
for not admitting that he's gotten his
coveted booster
um this is a really interesting
developing story so here's the back
story back in December Trump brown noser
Maria Bartiromo asked Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis also known as Ron death
sandis in some circles have you gotten
the booster and DeSantis didn't answer
the question okay so let me set the
stage with this original clip from
December Governor we're not even sure
what fully vaccinated means anymore the
other day Dr fauci said you know we
could be that fully vaccinated means
three shots which is two shots for the
vaccination and then one booster shot
have you gotten the booster
so yeah uh I've done whatever I did the
the normal shot and you know that at the
end of the day is people's individual
decisions about what they want to do
I've done whatever I've done yes right
and what we are trying to ascertain is
what is it that you have done but he
didn't answer but these boosters in
terms now Florida we don't we ban
vaccine passports we we won't let them
fire you even private businesses over
this because we don't think did you get
the booster in Florida we won't let them
fire you if you don't get the booster
right but the question was did you get
the booster so Donald Trump to his
credit to his credit as part of this
building fight between Trump and
DeSantis which is really it's an early
fight for the 2024 Republican nomination
don't be confused that it's anything
else Donald Trump astutely pointed out
that there are these politicians who
won't tell you if they got the booster
uh this was Trump when interviewed by
oan and he's talking about Ron DeSantis
here but he doesn't name him by name
it's something out there but after now
so many months of the vaccine being
administered and these side effects and
Americans questions of it do you
reconsider your push for it or what's
your view now on the vaccine in general
well I've taken it I've had the booster
many politicians I watched a couple of
politicians be interviewed and one of
the questions was did you get the
booster because they had the vaccine and
they oh they're answering it like in
other words the answer is yes but they
don't want to say it
because they're gutless right they say
it whether you had it or not say it but
the fact is that I think the vaccine has
saved tens of millions of people
throughout the world
I have had absolutely no side effects
I've had it like other people have said
Trump is we we know he's referring to
Ron DeSantis and Trump is increasingly
starting to attack DeSantis directly
Roger Stone has started to attack Ron
DeSantis DeSantis has started to back
away from Trump and say things like ah
maybe shouldn't have followed him quite
as much on covid leadership early in the
pandemic remember there was no such
leadership but it doesn't really matter
Ron DeSantis over the weekend was asked
again very directly did you get your
covet booster and now he is straight up
admitting he's not going to say why not
going to say whether he got it because
it's going to be used against him
so that's something that um you know I
think people should just make their own
decisions on um I'm not gonna but the
question was not whether we know others
should decide we're asking you Governor
what did you decide and then he says
he's not gonna he's not gonna say let
that be a weapon for people to be able
to use I think it's a private matter
we've worked hard to be able to protect
people uh so they don't lose their jobs
on that now understand that
DeSantis says his position is if I
understand it correctly
he got vaccinated he won't say if he got
boosted but he says he got vaccinated he
got vaccinated but they won't allow the
mandates in Florida
and they won't allow you to be fired
because you haven't been vaccinated so
the coherent position would be I did get
boosted and I don't believe anyone
should be fired if they don't get
boosted that's a completely coherent
position but DeSantis knows that his
Republican followers in Florida are so
weaponized and so uninformed that if he
just admits that he got the booster he
will get people who are mad at him for
that that's why because there's no it
wouldn't become a weapon if you say I've
chosen to get it and everybody should be
able to make the choice and no one
should be fired that's a that's a
coherent position it's not we don't have
to agree with the with the position but
it's coherent it shouldn't make any of
his followers mad but it will and that's
why DeSantis isn't admitting that he got
the booster I have said publicly that
you know the FDA recommended it against
boosters for people in my age group and
the CDC overrode that and I think that
was based on politics I don't think that
was based on science two of the top FDA
people actually resigned in protest many
people didn't hear about that remember
the question was did you get your
booster you know why well because it
didn't fit the narrative I can tell you
um if you had a different president of a
different party that would have been
hair on fire stuff you know that people
would have been able to do so in Florida
they've been available for people people
can make their own decisions on it but
it's not been something that um you know
that we've been telling people in my age
group you know to go out and do right
but again that that was not the question
the question was simply did you get the
booster and going very much out of his
way to avoid saying whether he did or
didn't I think he probably did uh his it
it would be crazy not to particularly
given that Ron desantis's wife is
currently undergoing treatment for
breast cancer it would be wholly
irresponsible for him not to get that
third dose given how effective it is at
preventing serious illness uh uh and and
uh according to what Vincent racanello
told us last week reducing the
possibility that you transmit the virus
to others so I think he probably did get
it but understand how weaponized the
people around him are that he can't even
admit it and Trump is right he should
you should just say it I either got it
or I didn't and deal with whatever the
consequences are we have a voicemail
number that number is
2192 David P here's kind of like a witch
would you rather and I I unders I'm I'm
aware that this voicemail may be asked
in bad faith of me I I don't know for
sure but I don't care I think it's an
interesting question and I have a very
clear answer so let's take a listen uh
if you want to leave a voicemail 219 to
David P
hey David I have a hypothetical question
for you would you rather step onto an
elevator with someone who is
unvaccinated
or would you rather step onto an
elevator with someone who is smoking a
cigarette
that's it just a hypothetical question
facade yeah no I mean it's it's a very I
would rather step into an elevator with
someone who is unvaccinated rather than
with someone emanating cigarette smoke
like a chimney
um if I wear a mask around someone who
is smoking a cigarette uh in an enclosed
place
I I think that that smoke gets through
just about every mask people can correct
me if I'm wrong yeah I think I think
even with an n95 cigarette smoke
particles are smaller than covid
um also if someone is unvaccinated on an
elevator with me it doesn't mean that
they are sick statistically they're not
sick so it seems like a very easy
question to answer and um you know
sometimes with these questions again the
reason it's sort of a weird question
maybe it's just a curiosity you know the
the answer is obvious to me but
sometimes people try to use these
questions as sort of gotchas like if I
say no I I'd rather be in the elevator
for for 20 seconds or whatever it is
with someone not vaccinated rather than
with someone emanating cigarette smoke
um you know there's no there's no
vaccine against conditions caused by
cigarette smoke I mean it just doesn't
make any sense it's like the the answer
is irrelevant to anything about vaccine
or mask policy and and that's why I
wonder
uh sort of like what the point of the
question is but if you disagree if
there's let me put it this way if
there's anyone in my audience who would
rather spend 20 or 30 seconds in an
elevator with someone smoking cigarettes
rather than with an unvaccinated person
masked or unmasked whatever it doesn't
doesn't matter for me the answer would
always be I'd rather it be uh with the
unvaccinated person it's a short amount
of time I can wear a mask I have three
vaccines so that that would be my answer
we are going to have a big story
tomorrow about what's happening with
Russia and Ukraine and the situation
does seem to be escalating there
significantly one of the elements of
that is that the U.S state department
has ordered the families of Embassy
staff in the U.S embassy in Ukraine to
leave the country and we're going to
talk about that on today's bonus show we
also are going to talk about
um New York City new New York city mayor
Eric Adams
uh who has taken I don't remember if
it's his whole salary or his first
payment in Bitcoin that has now been
devalued significantly because of the
decline in cryptocurrency markets so
we'll talk about Eric Adams I think
there are some NFL players or at least
one being paid in Bitcoin uh we're going
to talk about it I'll also talk about
what I have done if anything with my
Bitcoin hint I've done nothing that's uh
all almost always my strategy and
thirdly the Arizona Democratic party has
formally censured Kirsten Cinema
um and we are going to talk about like
what does that mean does that really do
anything what are the impacts of that
and what is it that uh does it does it
really have any repercussions for her at
all so that's all going on I hope you
will join me this Saturday evening uh
the next Donald Trump rally for the 2022
campaign season will be taking place in
Conroe Texas and as I mentioned earlier
if you live nearby and you can get there
we want to hire someone in the audience
to go to the rally interview people live
with me on on via Skype or Zoom we'll
figure out how to do it during our live
stream so get in touch info
davidpackman.com let me know what
equipment you have and the equipment
might just be like you know an iPhone
and a microphone you plug into it
um your ability to get there if you know
how you can get yourself in ETC we have
we're going to hire one person to do
this but get in touch info
davidpackman.com we have a fantastic
week of shows coming up for you and
remember that you can get instant access
to the bonus show by signing up at
joinpakman.com
thank you